the estate of David and Peggy
Rockefeller goes up for auction at
Christie's here in New York next week
the sale includes masterpieces by
Picasso Monet and Matisse it is expected
to be the highest-grossing single owner
auction in history Anthony Mason as a
preview of what some are calling the
sale of the century David and Peggy
Rockefellers four homes were filled with
masterpieces we never bought a painting
with a view towards forming a collection
David Rockefeller once wrote but simply
because in the end we couldn't resist it
welcome to the annual meeting of the
Chase Manhattan Corporation the longtime
chief of Chase Manhattan Bank he was the
grandson of America's first billionaire
john d rockefeller who made his fortune
in Standard Oil David's father built
Rockefeller Center were in a 2002
interview for Sunday morning he gave me
a tour of the family offices to Gertrude
Stein even here he surrounded himself
with the Masters of modern art is
collecting for you a compulsion
it's a pleasure a pleasure he could
indulge in as a member of what many
considered America's most powerful
family was the name ever a burden for
you I don't feel so I was sitting he
conscious of it there were moments I may
have felt awkward or embarrassed but
early on it was obvious as well as
disadvantages the name and the fortune
behind it helped David and his wife
Peggy accumulate one of the 20th
century's great art collections how
significant a collection is this it's
the most important collection of
paintings and sculpture that's ever been
sold the Rockefellers were crazy about
ceramics Mark Porter is chairman of
Christie's America's which will hold the
auction over three days next week the
sale includes this Monet estimate fifty
million dollars
Matisse's odalisque with magnolias this
man
he's painted in 1924 is the greatest
Matisse to come to market in 50 years
estimate 70 million dollars and arguably
the crown jewel of the collection she
looks pretty good the 1905 painting
young girl with a flower basket from
Picasso's rose period the estimate on
this picture is what we are giving
guidance of about 100 million dollars
100 million yes the Picasso which hung
in the family's New York Library had
belonged to American writer Gertrude
Stein one of 47 works bought in 1968 by
a syndicate that included David
Rockefeller his brother New York
Governor Nelson Rockefeller and CBS
founder William Paley they chose lots
out of a fell hat to get first pick and
as luck would have it David Rockefeller
got choice number one and the building
you're in now is the original timeline
for yes the auction which will be held
in Rockefeller Center was arranged by
David Rockefeller jr. after his father
died last year at 101 what was like
growing up with all of that around you
it limited the amount of ball play in
the house that's the negative part but
it did train us to appreciate beautiful
things the Rockefeller kids were also
given an early lesson in philanthropy
usually allowance was given on Sunday
morning and church was next you see your
party allowance you lost 10% in the
first hour all of the proceeds from this
go to charity by some estimates it could
bring a billion dollars to the
beneficiaries which include Harvard and
Rockefeller universities the Museum of
Modern Art and the Council on Foreign
Relations there are sixteen hundred Lots
in the sale everything in the family
houses everything from three or four
houses including furniture prized
porcelain and this is Napoleon's ice
cream bowl basically dispenser anyway it
is his ice cream bowl you would put ice
underneath
in the ice cream on top and then go to
town and the family jewelry this may be
my favorite thing in the auction along
with many other people I think it's this
is a Rockefeller Center money clip what
better to hold the stack of bills it
also includes some of the collection of
Rockefeller carriages so how far back in
family history would some of these go
well certainly a hundred years because
my grandfather was driving carriages
both before and after cars were invented
will you be at the auction yes I will
and rooting it on in effect oh darn
right we're gonna see the dispersal and
effect of one of the great art
collections of all time I mean is that
in any sense is that difficult for you
to watch maybe it will be that night but
I'm I'm thinking the better it goes the
happier I will be I think you know that
mattiece if it goes into hands where I
think I'll never see it again that will
be hard for me other than that this is a
game and I'm on the same side as
Christie's on this one because we're
both trying to create a huge success for
the benefit of wonderful institutions
feel like you get a piece of history and
then a piece of history on top of it
exactly right these are some of the most
beautiful art pieces I've ever seen in
my life that I will ever see but I
probably you know I'll go for a thimble
cannot afford any other or the same the
two of us Navy